ich rufe auf die tagesordnungspunkte 33a
bis 33 c beratung der
beschlussempfehlung des
haushaltsausschusses zum antrag der
fraktionen der cdu/csu und spd mit dem
titel beschluss des deutschen
bundestages gemäß artikel 115 absatz 2
satz 6 und 7 des grundgesetzes sowie
zweite und dritte beratung des von der
bundesregierung eingebrachten entwurfs
eines nachtragshaushaltsgesetzes 2021
und beratung der beschlussempfehlung des
ausschusses für wirtschaft und energie
zum antrag der fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen mit dem titel für
wirtschaftshilfen die schnell
unkompliziert und zuverlässig helfen
zum entwurf eines
nachtragshaushaltsgesetzes 2021 der
bundesregierung liegt je ein
entschließungsantrag der fraktionen der
fdp und der fraktion bündnis 90/die
grünen vor über die beschlussempfehlung
des haushaltsausschusses zum antrag der
fraktionen der cdu/csu und spd zur
artikel 115 absatz 2 satz 6 und 7 des
grundgesetzes werden wir später wie sie
wissen namentlich abstimmen
jetzt kommt was wichtiges zur annahme
dieser beschlussempfehlung ist die
absolute mehrheit von 355 stimmen
erforderlich
die fraktion der afg hat die
verlängerung der debatten zeit von 30
minuten auf 60 minuten beantragt und
dazu gebe ich jetzt das wort dem
kollegen peter böhringer
so also erstmal eine
geschäftsordnungsdebatte führen wenn man
peter böhringer für die fraktion
guten morgen frau präsidentin verehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen das haushalts
feststellung es recht nach artikel 110
grundgesetz ist ja bekanntlich das
königsrecht des parlaments
es gibt kaum ein vorhaben der regierung
das nicht mit budget unterlegt werden
müssen
reguläre aussieht warten im bundestag
wurden darum praktisch immer über zwei
wochen mit etwa 40 stunden debatten zeit
geführt und ja es ist schon der siebte
haushalt dieser legislaturperiode
schlimm genug an
zudem werden wir heute auch noch
aufgefordert die verfassungsrechtlichen
notsituationen gemäß artikel 115
grundgesetz auszurufen und
milliardenschwer auszuweiten
und ja es ist nur ein nachtragshaushalt
doch selbst nur der nachtrag und fast 60
milliarden euro
in diesem haus werden oftmals schon
anträge und gesetze mitunter einem
tausendstel dieses volumens in 60
minuten and beraten den 21 haushalt
schrauben wir heute mit der
schlussabstimmung auf ein volumen von
547 milliarden bei 240 milliarden euro
neuverschuldung beides die größten werte
der deutschen geschichte
die altparteien haben sie diese woche
trotzdem und für uns völlig überraschend
und natürlich auch gegen die stimmen der
afg auf eine debatten zeit für die
heutige zweite und dritte
haushaltsberatung von nur 30 minuten
verständigt irgendwie soll damit wohl
eine art routine suggeriert werden
trotz der genannten rekordwerte es sei
irgendwie alles gesagt alles solide
alles normal das ist die botschaft die
mit diesem zeitlichen minimal ansatz
verbreitet werden sollen
wir können aus halls debatten aber nicht
so unbedeutend 30 minuten routine
herabwürdigen bei nachträgen dieser
größenordnung ist es auch noch nie zuvor
auch nur vorgeschlagen worden
und auch die aussprachen im nicht
öffentlichen ausschuss können die
streitbaren diskussion hier im plenum
nicht ersetzen
die halbierung von 60 auf 30 minuten
hätte nicht nur die zwingende praktische
folge einer schlicht unzureichenden
debatte sondern wäre auch symbolisch ein
fatales signal dass ein zu 44 prozent
auf schulden aufgebaut auszeit irgendwie
normal sei und ohne weitere worte
passieren kann
die koalitionsfraktionen selbst hatte
noch vor wenigen tagen 60 minuten für
den heutigen tagesordnungspunkt
vorgesehen gehabt entsprechend dem
langjährigen muss es eben und wie ich
gestern aus dem ältestenrat höhere zieht
auch bundestagspräsident der präsident
die debatten von nur 30 minuten in der
kann zeitkritisch der fdp fraktion
beantragt darum die heutige wichtige
debatte wieder auf die absolute minimum
sind seit von 60 minuten hoch zu stufen
ich werbe dafür um ihre zustimmung
dankeschön
[Applaus]
antrag der fdp fraktion peter böhringer
hierfür die ap formuliert hat er ist
auch vorsitzender des
haushaltsausschusses
ich danke ihnen und das wort zur
gegenrede hat kassen schneider carsten
schneider sagte geschäftsführer der
spd-fraktion
guten morgen frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
wir sind am freitagmorgen 9 uhr in der
kernzeit der bundesfinanzminister ist da
wir beraten die den nachtragshaushalt
des bundestages und er für die
bundesrepublik ganz substanzieller ist
ein wichtiger beitrag in der
stabilisierung unserer volkswirtschaft
jetzt geht es um 30 minuten mehr oder
weniger wir haben hier gestern das
inszenieren sie habe ringer als würden
wir unsere arbeit nicht machen wir haben
wir gestern mittwoch lange getagt haben
gestern bisher mit erwartete tagen ja
heute bis 18 uhr
wir haben sehr sehr viele
debattenbeiträgen gesetze die wir in den
nächsten wochen bundestag noch
debattieren und beschließen wollen wir
tun das in klarer demokratischer manier
und auch ausbrach
sie hatten
sie hatten gelegenheit im
haushaltsausschuss alle fragen zu
stellen die notwendig sind um für ihre
fragen die sie eventuell haben an bord
zu bekommen
sie hatten die möglichkeit auch gehabt
weiteren ministerien als nur die
betroffenen einzelpläne also gesundheit
und wirtschaftliche hilfen in frage zu
stellen oder auch zu anzuhören das haben
sie nicht getan
es gab eine sondersitzung in dem der
bundesfinanzminister vorgetragen der
bundesfinanzminister hat den
gesetzentwurf eingebracht der wird jetzt
auch widersprechen mehr transparenz
geben einfach nicht deswegen ihre
kolleginnen kollegen
wir müssen zu einer entscheidung kommen
wir wollen entscheiden wir wohl nicht
verhindern wir wollen nicht sand im
getriebe sein wie die afg sondern wir
wollen dass es läuft in deutschland
dafür brauchen wir diesen bundeshaushalt
insbesondere auch mal für die hilfen die
wir für junge familien für diejenigen
schülerinnen und schüler die unter dem
problem von kroner leiden dass die lern
schwachsinn da haben wir veränderungen
gemacht keine vorschläge von hinten eine
obstruktion
der bundestag ist kern der debatte das
machen wir aber auch die entscheidung
das neue morgen dann fielen carsten
schneider
damit kommen wir zur abstimmung über den
geschäftsordnungsantrag der s&d-fraktion
wer stimmt für diesen antrag
ich danke ihnen wer stimmt dagegen
dankeschön wer enthält sich gibt es
nicht der geschäftsordnungs antrag ist
abgelehnt zugestimmt hat die fdp
fraktion abgelehnt wurde er von allen
anderen fraktionen des hauses damit
bleibt es also bei der beschlossenen
debatten dauer von 30 minuten und die
debatte eröffne ich jetzt und gäbe als
erster redner das wort dem
bundesminister olaf scholz für die
bundesregierung
wer also jetzt beginnt frau präsidentin
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren am
mittwoch haben wir die bundes notbremse
hier im deutschen bundestag beschlossen
der bundesrat unterdessen zugestimmt und
das gesetz ist so weit dass es nun in
kraft treten kann
das alles ist gemacht worden damit wir
die dritte welle der pandemie brechen
können und es zeigt die lage ist ernst
wir müssen etwas tun aber wir handeln
was wir heute tun ist dass wir über
einen ergänzenden baustein diskutieren
etwas was wir machen um ebenfalls dafür
zu sorgen dass wir diese pandemie
überwinden und eine bessere zeit
erreichen und dazu dient der
nachtragshaushalt es geht darum nach
vorne zu kommen
die pandemie zu überwinden es geht um
mittel für den gesundheitsschutz
und es geht um finanzielle unterstützung
wie die überbrückungshilfe 3 und viele
viele
unterstützung für unternehmen und
arbeitnehmern und arbeitnehmer da der
bundestag die pandemische notlage bis
zum 30 juni festgestellt hat haben wir
auch die unterstützungsleistung
verlängert und ausgebaut
zusätzliche unternehmenshilfen sind
bewilligt worden die impfstoffe
beschaffung wird besser unterstützt und
die impfung test kampagne sowie der
kinderbonus sind für 2021 vorgesehen
massive finanzielle unterstützung für
die ganze gesellschaft
[Applaus]
sie kommen auch an die unternehmens
hilft zum beispiel auf bundesebene sind
bereits fast 95 milliarden euro
abgeflossen
und das ohne die mittel für kurzarbeit
und die steuerrechtlichen maßnahmen
fallen das sichert die wirtschaftliche
leistungsfähigkeit all das ist die
grundlage dafür dass deutschland
wirtschaftlich besser durch die krise
gekommen dass selbst viele viele andere
länder und wir sagen heute wir werden
das bis zum ende der ganzen zeit
durchhalten wir stehen bei den bürgern
bei den arbeitnehmern arbeitet jemand
und bei den unternehmen
denn nach der pandemie wollen wir
durchstarten
wir werden wieder miteinander und nicht
zu hause auf abstand sein das
gesellschaftliche leben wird wieder voll
da sein
die kinder in ihren schulen und kitas
und wir werden im spätsommer hoffentlich
wieder in einem biergarten sitzen können
und wir werden auch wirtschaftlich
wieder durchstarten können die
arbeitnehmerinnen arbeitnehmer die in
kurzarbeit sind werden zurückkehren
können an ihren arbeitsplatz die vielen
selbstständigen und künstlern werden
wieder ihrer tätigkeit nachgehen können
dass das möglich ist müssen wir jetzt
planen dafür tragen wir vorsorge mit
diesem nachtragshaushalt
es geht um geld aber es geht um viel
mehr es geht um die zukunft und den
wiederaufstieg in unserem land das ist
ein teil der hoffnung die mir sehr
wichtig ist durchstarten heißt auch erst
recht nach der pandemie haben wir unsere
zukunft aufgaben zu lösen und sie müssen
unsere große aufmerksamkeit haben
es geht um unsere wirtschaftliche stärke
in den 20er jahren um sichere
arbeitsplätze den klimaschutz und die
moderne digitale infrastruktur um nur
ein paar sehr wichtige aufgaben zu
nehmen wir brauchen ein hohes niveau an
investitionen in den klimaschutz in den
digitalen wandel und die mobilitäts und
energiewende
damit die innovationen gelingen müssen
wir aber auch hohe investitionen im
bundeshaushalt absichern
und das geschieht mit dem was wir hier
tun 59 milliarden in diesem jahr 50
milliarden in all den folgejahren
das ist ein rekordniveau ein notwendiges
aber ein richtiges rekordniveau für
investitionen in die zukunft
[Applaus]
der bundeshauptstadt aber nicht nur aus
ausgaben sondern auch aus einbringen
und deshalb ist es mir ganz wichtig dass
wir gerade dabei sind wie selige
fortschritte stück für stück
voranzubringen die notwendig sind in dem
wir nämlich für eine faire steuerpolitik
kämpfen indem wir uns dafür einsetzen
der steuervermeidung und der
internationalen steuer verlagen
entgegenzutreten
ihr kollege stolz sind sie offen für
eine zwischenfrage oder bemerkungen vom
kollegen fritschi fdp
ich danke diese großzügigkeit herr
minister der minister da sie ja keine
einzige minute nachdem sie ganz am
anfang mal kurz im haushalt vorgestellt
haben keine einzige minute während der
haushaltsberatungen im
haushaltsausschuss waren und jetzt hier
gesagt haben dass sie die investitionen
hochgefahren haben würde ich sie fragen
ob es stimmt dass sie in den
haushaltsberatungen als koalition die
investitionen wieder runtergefahren
haben im milliardenbeträgen
das ist ein freak und dann dank für ihre
frage wir haben hier eine sehr
langfristige investitionspolitik und ich
sage das noch mal
jedes jahr werden in den künftigen
jahren 50 milliarden sein und wir werden
in diesem jahr 59 milliarden haben ich
habe es bereits berichtet ist eine ganz
starke investitionspolitik und es ist
etwas was man glaube ich nicht in jeder
koalition zustande kriegt aber in dieser
abend ist immerhin geschafft und das ist
ein guter fortschritt und will zurück zu
dem was wir was ich eben versucht habe
anzufangen nämlich darauf hinzuweisen
man darf nicht nur über das geld das man
ausgibt redet und man muss auch darüber
reden wie wir die richtigen einnahmen
haben indem wir für faire steuern und
für gegen steuervermeidung und
steuerfrage rund 1 sätzen und deshalb
hier der hinweis auf eine ganze reihe
von vorhaben die gegenwärtig im gange
sind zum beispiel dass steueroasen
abwehr gesetzt zum beispiel die regelung
zu den share deals die nun was geworden
ist zum beispiel die beratung über die
anti steuer vermeidungs richtlinie alles
das gehört zu dem gefüge unserer
haushaltspolitik dazu weil es dazu
beiträgt dass
eine krise die in dieser art und weise
stattfindet auch und dem nationalstaaten
bekämpft werden kann weil es keine
verlagerung gibt und deshalb und deshalb
braucht das noch zum schluss
wir haben einen großen aufschlag der
jetzt möglich wird auch in der
verbindung mit der neuen amerikanischen
regierung dass wir eine effektive
globale mindestbesteuerung der welt
durchsetzen
wenn das jetzt eine der folgenden
pandemie ist dann ist das etwas was uns
weiterhelfen weit nach der zeit wenn die
pandemie vielleicht nur noch eine
erinnerung ist schön danke vielen dank
an bmi beginnt das bedingte ausgaben wie
etwa für die eben von tests kampagne
aber auch steuer mindereinnahmen von
rund neun milliarden für hilfen wie den
kinderbonus all das trägt dazu bei dass
wir nochmals seine neuverschuldung für
das kommende jahr um weitere 60 4
milliarden euro auf dem papier stehen
haben und darüber wird jetzt noch einmal
debattiert es fängt für die afg an
volker menz liebe kollegen meine damen
und herren mit dem nachtragshaushalt
sollen noch einmal 60 milliarden euro
mehr schulden aufgenommen werden als
geplant
damit wird für das laufende jahr eine
neuverschuldung von gigantischen 240
milliarden euro veranschlagt fast die
hälfte des bundeshaushalts wird über
neuverschuldung finanziert so etwas hat
es noch nie gegeben meine damen und
herren
[Musik]
dies funktioniert nur weil wieder einmal
die im grundgesetz verankerte
schuldenbremse durch feststellung einer
notsituation aufgehoben werden soll
dem werden wir nicht zustimmen meine
damen und herren
diese schuldenorgie ist unverantwortlich
und geschieht auf kosten der
nachkommenden generationen hinzu kommen
die auch noch die mithaftung
deutschlands für die schuldenaufnahme
der eu und für die euro rettung
auch der bundesrechnungshof kritisiert
die haushaltsplanung deutlich die
haushaltslage sei besorgniserregend
wegen der schuldenlawine zitat
bundesrechnungshof es werden
insbesondere zusätzliche corona
unternehmenshilfen veranschlagt ja diese
zahlungen an die unternehmen sind
notwendig es sind auch keine hilfe
sondern de facto teil entschädigungen
für monatelange umsatzausfälle und
berufsverbote aufgrund staatlicher
anordnung meine damen und herren statt
immer hemmungsloser schulden zu machen
gehört die gesamte ausgabenseite auf den
prüfstand strukturelle änderungen sind
notwendig in der aktuellen lage müssen
dann eben bereiche die mit corona nichts
zu tun haben gekürzt werden statt immer
mehr aufgestockt werden
die gigantischen ausgaben und liefern
dunk von volkswirtschaftlichen vermögen
durch die energiewende sollten
wenigstens in der jetzigen situation
drastisch zurückgefahren und maßnahmen
wie das abschalten von kraftwerken
zumindest ausgesetzt werden
dieser bundeshaushalt ist unsolide die
neu verschuldung in dieser höhe
unverantwortlich die afd wird dem
nachtragshaushalt nicht zustimmen wir
werden ablehnen meine damen und herren
[Applaus]
war das für die afg fraktion was folgt
jetzt für die cdu csu fraktion deren
haushaltspolitischer sprecher
[Musik]
[Applaus]
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen bevor ich
zum ausdruck kommen
ein wort zur entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts zum eigenen
beschluss der sehr zu begrüßen dass die
einstweilige anordnung abgelehnt worden
ist in der bundespräsident unterzeichnen
kann
habe ich grade eben auch in der finanz
minister scholz und ihn der
staatsminister roth sich die 49 seiten
gründlich durchzulesen und ihr hat
vossloh sehr deutlich gemacht dass das
einmalig ist temporär und das ist kein
einstieg in eine fiskal strecke schulden
union sein kann und deswegen warte ich
in alle rühren gelassenheit auf die
entscheidung in der hauptsache ab und da
die ich davon aus dass karlsruhe hier
schon verleiht planken einziehen wird
die der rechtsauffassung der jungs
fraktion und die wir gemeinsam mit der
spd in unserem antrag zum ausdruck
gebracht haben nochmal unterstützen und
und ersetzen wird
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
dieser haushalt 20 21 unter nachtrag die
müssen reichen in anführungsstrichen bis
ins nächste jahr
und deswegen ist es richtig dass die
vorsorge getroffen haben
wir haben eine bundestagswahl für uns
wir haben das ende der legislaturperiode
fonds wir haben dann vor und seine zeit
für eine bundesregierung nur hantiert
und dann glaube ich ist es klug die
unternehmenshilfen noch einmal
aufgestockt zu haben und auch gerade für
die pandemievorsorge übrigens wir haben
schon 25 milliarden euro in diesem jahr
zusätzlich geld ausgegeben testen im
stoffen krankenhausfinanzierung
und deswegen ist es klug auch mit blick
auf die vorläufige haushaltsführung das
hier so zu machen wie wir es getan haben
der kollege dürfen die korrekten zahlen
sind folgende bei den unternehmens
hilfen beantragt worden sind insgesamt
rund 21 milliarden euro davon sind bei
den november und dezember hilfen
deswegen glaube ich tun wir uns alle
keinen gefallen
ständig zu lamentieren dass hier nicht
ausgezahlt wird 85 prozent im schnitt in
deutschland ausgezahlt worden
von mitte 60 bis über 90 prozent in
mecklenburg-vorpommern liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen und auch bei der
überbrückungshilfe drei antragsvolumen
steigt stetig übrigens sind fast 50
prozent der beantragten mittel
ausgereicht worden und deswegen glaube
ich das funktioniert jetzt das system
und dass wir hier noch mal erweitert
haben das auch richtig stichwort nochmal
eine verbesserung eigenkapital zuschuss
und einsatz sagen zur der
pandemievorsorge
wir haben jetzt zehn milliarden euro bei
den verpflichtungsermächtigungen drauf
gepackt ich halte es für richtig
niemand weiß müssen wir eine
auffrischungsimpfung vornehmen niemand
weiß sind die impfungen die heute werde
das freude für imst wird die impfstoffe
wirklich immun eine dauer immunität und
deswegen glaube ich ist das richtig und
auch niemand kann eine prognose wagen
wie wir die situation seien bei den
krankenhäusern wir haben dann in dem
nachtragshaushalt noch mal dafür gesorgt
ein ganz wichtiges zukunftsthema dass
deutschland sich heute schon wasserstoff
weltweit beschaffen kann mit verträgen
für die nächsten zehn jahre teamkollegen
kollegen es wird ein rennen auch grünen
wasserstoff auch auf derivate weltweit
losgehen und deswegen haben wir hier
dafür gesorgt umschichtung dass hier das
bundeswirtschaftsministerium
handlungsfähig ist die deutsche bahn
darf betroffen ist es noch nicht der
schadensausgleich ist der ausgleich für
die dividende die in die luft geht damit
weiter in stand gehalten werden kann und
das sind 20 module reduzierung der
trassenpreise beim
sheen personenfernverkehr und beim
schienengüterverkehr das sind
branchenlösungen diese lösung gelten
nicht nur für die deutsche bahn des
schadens ausgleich konnte später nur in
einem nebensatz
die koalition hat den vorstand der bahn
ag und deren töchter die sind genau
genannt das sie auf variable vergütung
verzichten
die kolleginnen kollegen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die
zinsausgaben steigen um viereinhalb
milliarden
was sagt das all dem gibt eine kleine
anfrage der fdp
wir werden oder wir haben stand heute
das bunt 1000 1200 30 milliarden euro
schulden
da sollen in diesem jahr 240 hinzu
kommen das wird wahrscheinlich nicht
ganz so sein aber ich rechne mal
vielleicht ende 2022 mit 1500 milliarden
schulden
wenn nur die zinsen um 10 basispunkte
steigen dann sind das 1,5 milliarden
wenn sie um 40 5 6 milliarden und das
kumuliert sich dank 6 und 6 und 6 0 6
das muss man jetzt nicht beschreien aber
allein dieses jahr kam die runde 300
milliarden umzuwälzen an dieser stelle
und wie gesagt man hat nur noch die
zehnjährigen bundesanleihen in leichten
- die 30 jährige nicht nur deswegen
liebe kolleginnen kollegen sollten wir
wirklich unter hat paragon
generalsekretär recht schnellstmöglich
wieder zur schuldenbremse zurückkommen
sollten wirklich alles dazu
an diese stelle zu sagen so
nachhaltigkeit gehört klimaschutz zur
nachhaltigkeit gehört digitalisierung in
deutschland
aber deutschland hat stark gemacht
gerade auch im letzten jahrzehnten dass
wir 1 verbunden haben solide
haushaltspolitik und wachstumspolitik
und nur deswegen der
bundesfinanzminister stolz sind wir so
gut in die krise reingekommen und ich
hoffe dass wir die lösungen die wir nach
der letzten finanzkrise vorgenommen
haben wieder nehmen und noch eine letzte
bemerkung nicht die staatsquote ist die
entscheidende quote immer schulden
herauszukommen sondern die kredit
finanzierungsquote des bundeshaushalt
ist wie es leider in diesem jahr 44
prozent in 2007 war sie nur 15 prozent
herzlichen dank angesprochen und die ist
ja bereits vom bundestag für letztes
jahr noch für dieses jahr überhaupt
diese rekord neuverschuldung möglich zu
machen
das grundgesetz sieht ja eben eine
schuldenbremse vor aber auch heute muss
wegen dieser noch höhere neuverschuldung
nochmals über die aussetzung der schuld
werden ist das haushalterische
gegenstück zum infektionsschutzgesetz
vom mittwoch die öffentlichkeit fragt
sich verwundert und reibt sich die augen
wo eigentlich die zahlen herkommen
und was das konkret gegen die bekämpfung
der pandemie ausrichten soll dieser
haushalt beispiel unternehmenshilfen da
mangelt ist ja nicht an haushaltsmitteln
herr kollege reben ist ja nicht so dass
der haushalt leergelaufen soll allein
die rest aus dem jahr 2020 sondern es
mangelt an der umsetzung man hat den
eindruck sie stellen die gießkannen
leben die pflanze ohne zu gießen wundern
sich dass sie vertrocknet und die
antwort der großen koalition lautet dann
lasst uns mehr wasser in die gießkanne
tun darf hatte vernünftige
haushaltspolitik und unternehmenshilfen
überhaupt gar nichts zu tun liebe
kollegen ab kollegen wie viel besser
wäre es gewesen spätestens jetzt ich
sage das in richtung der kollegen der
cdu csu herr kollege brinkhaus der
fraktions größten wie viel besser wäre
es gewesen unseren vorschlag einer
negativen gewinnsteuern das was alle
ökonomen in deutschland sagen endlich
den steuerlichen verlust rückt rat
deutlich auszuweiten hier jetzt
umzusetzen das wären unternehmenshilfen
für die mittelstadt in deutschland
gewesen herr blick auf sie haben nichts
dazu beigetragen
außer moralische reden vom mittwoch um
das sind aller kleid zu sagen und
zweitens es gibt hier auch keinerlei
anstrengung überflüssige unnötige
ausgaben einmal zu überprüfen
stattdessen arbeiten sie mit dem schönen
kürzel gm leider nicht globale
minderausgabe sondern globale ausgabe
die globale mehrausgabe ist nichts
anderes als wir haben keinen blassen
schimmer was wir mit dem geld machen
wollen aber wir stellen es in
schaufenster um den kanzlerkandidaten
der spd sein wahlkampf zu versüßen das
hat mit corona pandemie bekämpfung
nichts zu tun liebe kollegen deswegen
ist dieser haushalt überflüssig
und das bei einer rücklage herr scholz
von 50 milliarden euro da liegen 50
milliarden euro in der rücklage und es
werden 60 milliarden euro neue schulden
gemacht und an dieser stelle will ich
unterstreichen
das funktioniert so nicht auch nicht bei
den unternehmen zu helfen weiß ich es
gerade hier noch mal behauptet haben ihr
kollege benutzt ihr diese zahlen auch
sie haben gesagt wir haben 95 milliarden
euro unternehmenshilfen ausgegeben ich
bin dankbar rebek dass sie das gerade
klar gestellt haben die wahrheit ist es
sind nicht 95 milliarden euro der
großteil davon sind kredite die der
deutsche mittelstand cent für cent
zurückzahlen muss die unternehmenshilfen
sind gerade mal 22 milliarden
so etwas zu erzählen und dann zu
behaupten die unternehmer sollen nicht
meckern ist ein skandal es geht viel
mittelstädten schlecht in deutschland
und sie tut nichts um ihnen zu helfen
und dass die investitionsquote
zurückgeht hat der kollege frick in
seiner nachfrage noch mal unterstrichen
sie mussten es ja zugeben ich will dass
zum schluss sagen dieser bundeshaushalt
trägt nicht dazu bei dass zügiger genf
wird es wird nicht mehr getestet in
deutschland und die korona hilfen werden
nicht schneller ausgezahlt und trotzdem
machen sie 60 milliarden euro
zusätzliche schulden
noch nie war der satz so richtig über
gesetze wenn es nicht notwendig ist ein
gesetz zu machen liebe kollegen dann ist
es notwendig kein gesetz zu machen und
das geht auch für diesen
nachtragshaushalt vielen dank christian
das für die extraktion der
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
er hatte einen punkt formuliert den die
fdp auch hier nochmal in form eines
entschließungsantrages der gleich
abgestellt werden muss ein bringt
nämlich die weitere erhöhung der
globalen mehrausgaben die fdp sagt das
sei nicht nötig hören wir mal für die
linke was gesine lötzsch zu sagen hat
vielen dank frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren es gibt
nachweislich gewinner und verlierer der
pandemie aber das ist kein naturgesetz
sondern ergebnis politischer
entscheidungen und hier muss sich
grundlegend etwas ändert meine damen und
herren
darum stellen wir als linke zwei fragen
an den nachtragshaushalt erstens zieht
er die gewinner zur finanzierung des
gemeinwesens heran und zweitens
unterstützt er die verlierer
wirkungsvoll
beide fragen muss ich mit nein
beantworten und das ist wirklich fatal
meine damen und herren
nehmen wir das beispiel der
selbstständigen dass deutschland sie tut
für wirtschaftsforschung hat eine studie
hervor vorgelegt aus der hervorgeht dass
frauen die selbstständig sind mit einer
60 prozent höheren wahrscheinlichkeit
härter von der pandemie betroffen sind
als selbstständige männer und diese
ungleichheit können wir nicht
akzeptieren
hier muss gegengesteuert werden meine
damen und herren die handeln wie
rechnungen verschicken sie jetzt schon
an alle privathaushalte
doch was ist mit der wirtschaft die
produktion läuft in vielen bereichen
einfach so weiter als ob es keine
pandemie gebe wir fordern dass die
menschen in der produktion effektiv
geschützt werden aber das ist ihm zu
anstrengend sie wollen der wirtschaft
nicht zu nahe treten hier brauchen wir
endlich einen effektiven schutz der
menschen die in der wirtschaft arbeiten
meine damen und herren
und wir müssen auch die frage stellen
wenn die freiheitsrechte der wirtschaft
mehr als die rechte von einzelnen
menschen
ich sage wenn wir nicht systemrelevante
produktion zum beispiel die
rüstungsindustrie reduzieren dann wäre
das eine wirksame maßnahme damit wäre
allen geholfen und die gesundheit würde
geschützt
im nachtragshaushalt steht immer noch
nicht wer die korona rechnung bezahlen
soll
die vermögenden sind in der krise noch
reicher geworden und die zunehmende
ungleichverteilung zwischen oben und
unten ist eine gefahr für unsere
demokratie
der deutsche gewerkschaftsbund fordert
jetzt eine vermögenssteuer das ist gut
unter der überschrift
steuergerechtigkeit herstellen
staatsfinanzen stärken schlägt der
deutsche gewerkschaftsbund nicht nur die
wiedereinführung einer vermögenssteuer
vor sondern plädiert auch für höhere
erbschafts und körperschaftsteuer wir
als linke sagen das ist der richtige weg
nun ist ja die schuldenbremse hier
wieder gelobt worden und die behauptung
aufgestellt worden die schuldenbremse
stünde für nachhaltigkeit und
generationengerechtigkeit wir sagen
ihnen ganz deutlich das gegenteil ist
der fall
die schuldenbremse ist etwas was gegen
nachhaltigkeit und gegen
generationengerechtigkeit steht die
schuldenbremse ist eine
investitionsbremse darum gehört sie
abgeschafft meine damen und herren wir
sind in westeuropa investitionen
schlusslicht das muss sich ändern wir
lehnen den nachtragshaushalt ab ein
gerechter haushalt sieht anders aus
vielen dank vielen dank
ich danke ihnen nächste rednerin für die
fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen anja
haltung und die sich der spd fraktions
position der bündnisgrünen fraktion sehr
geehrte frau präsidentin meine damen und
herren dieser nachtragshaushalt ist
notwendig wir haben das ja auch schon im
letzten jahr festgestellt wir müssen auf
die krise mit schnellen und wirksamen
und ausreichenden hilfen reagieren
ausdrückliche unterstützung auch von
unserer grünen fraktion
man kann das ganze auch so beschreiben
wir haben von der kredit erlaubnis im
jahr 2020 mit über 60 mit über 80
milliarden nicht gebrauch gemacht und
jetzt im jahr 20 21 beantragen wir
nochmal 60 milliarden mehr nicht
gebrauch gemacht haben wir weil
teilweise die hilfen auch nicht gut
umgesetzt wurden das haben wir auch
kritisiert mit blick auf die
wirtschaftshilfen aber faktisch bedeutet
ist dass die kreditaufnahme erlaubnis um
die wir heute noch mal abstimmen
faktisch eine verschiebung ist von 20 20
auf 20 21 in der summe der gesamtjahre
zur krisenbekämpfung ist das ziemlich
gleich hoch das mal zur einordnung in
richtung fdp und afd
wenn sie das für überflüssig und falsch
halten
und wenn sie das geißeln dann bedeutet
das auch dass sie eben
sich von den notwendigen ausgaben für
die krankenhäuser für die
wirtschaftshilfen für die unterstützung
von solo selbstständigen und von den und
das kurzarbeitergeld dass sie das gar
nicht anscheinend faktisch mittragen
wollen und das müssen sie dann auch mal
ehrlich zugeben frau kollegin frau
kollegin erlauben sie eine zwischenfrage
oder bemerkungen aus der fdp fraktion
ja natürlich kollegen in haydock vielen
dank dass die zwischenfrage zu lassen
ich möchte sie noch mal fragen zu den
cut von ihnen getroffenen aussagen zum
thema wirtschafts hinten lagen im
haushalt 2021 39,5 milliarden euro bis
jetzt in circa 15 milliarden euro
abgeflossen
die große koalition möchte jetzt 25 5
milliarden euro zusätzlich oben drauf
setzen damit 65 milliarden euro werden
zu 15 milliarden euro
mittelabfluss bei dem thema pandemie
bekämpfung liegen 35 milliarden euro
je nach rechnung letztens im
haushaltsausschuss 17 milliarden euro
bisher gebunden
ich glaube beides zeigt sehr deutlich
dass noch milliarden in diesem haushalt
stecken die nicht gebunden und auch
nicht verausgabt sind und die zur
pandemie bekämpfen und für
wirtschaftshilfen zur verfügung stehen
unser vorschlag war dass wir die mai
steuerschätzung abwarten um den haushalt
auch bei den einnahmen nach ziehen zu
können denn auch da werden große
veränderungen eintreten möchte ich die
schon fragen ob es wirklich solide
haushaltspolitik ist jetzt im april
dann haut nachtragshaushalt zu
beschließen wenn im mai die
steuerschätzung kommt nicht mal in einem
halben monat und dann auf solider basis
wie sich für den deutschen bundestag
gehört einen nachtragshaushalt zu
beschließen das ist das anliegen der
freien demokraten und ich finde jeder
solide haushälter frau kollegin hajduk
solle sich dieser sache anschließend hat
möchte ich sie fragen ob sie da eine
andere auffassung haben kollege klein
ich gehe erst mal davon aus dass sie
diese verschiebungen die ich
gekennzeichnet habe der gesamtkredit
aufnahme auch anerkennen aber ich will
sagen sie haben im grunde mit ihrer
frage ein argument auch geliefert warum
wir in diesem jahr für die
wirtschaftshilfen mehr geld brauchen
ich bin nämlich mit ihnen einer
kritischen meinung dass das nicht in
ordnung war dass die wirtschaftshilfen
im letzten jahr schlecht umgesetzt
wurden zu kompliziert waren dass selbst
viele unternehmerinnen und unternehmer
in die krise gestürzt dass das jetzt
fließt wie eckhardt rehberg gesagt hat
ist ja schön aber nach unserer
einschätzung hätte das schneller gehen
müssen aber das heißt dann auch dass wir
dieses jahr größere summen brauchen
außerdem haben wir den lockdown
verlängern müssten sie wissen auch als
wir den haushalt beschlossen haben
hatten wir die hoffnung dass nach dem
ersten quartal vielleicht besserung
eintritt wir laufen in ein zweites
quartal
was schwierig ist meine fraktion erkennt
an dass wir vorsorge treffen müssen für
hilfen für unternehmerinnen und
unternehmer hilfen für mehr
kurzarbeitergeld hilfen für auch ein
aufschlag für hartz4 bezieher das
kritisieren wir und verstehen es
überhaupt nicht dass die bundesregierung
das nicht macht und deswegen glauben wir
dass es richtig ist vorsorge zu treffen
mit diesem nachtragshaushalt am ende ist
das auch immer nur eine ausgabe
ermächtigung und das mit blick in einem
wahljahr wo wir noch viel wettbewerb
haben werden ist das eine wichtige
sicherheit und garantien und botschaft
an die bürgerinnen und bürger und
deswegen muss ich dabei bleiben sie
sorgen nicht für eine sichere
finanzierung fürs impfen fürs testen für
krankenhäuser und andere und deswegen
ist ihre ablehnung dieses
nachtragshaushalt zu kritisieren fehlen
dann ein bisschen halt ich fahre ford in
meiner rede
ich habe auch und wir haben auch kritik
an diesem haushalt und deswegen weil das
gefragt wurde werden wir uns enthalten
ich habe das gesagt wir finden dass die
hilfe nicht ausreichen bezogen auf
menschen die grundsicherung beziehen und
wir kritisieren auch dass die
tilgungsfrist für dieses programm zu
knapp bemessen ist
es ist schon interessant dass der
kanzlerkandidat der cdu in nordrhein
westfalen die tilgungsfrist für diese
große kreditaufnahme in seinem lang
zusammen mit der fdp
auf 50 jahre setzt und sie wollen dass
hier auf 20 jahre befristen wir grünen
finden dass es nicht nötig und wir sind
ja in guter gesellschaft ökonomen wie
der chef des deutschen instituts für
wirtschaft hüther spricht auch davon ist
sehr wahrscheinlich viel vernünftiger
eine tilgungsfrist von 40 antwort zu
sehen aber ich komme zu meinem letzten
punkt was ist die große linie der
finanzpolitik der zukunft wir brauchen
ab dem jahr 2023 wieder eine
konsolidierung bei den laufenden
ausgaben aber wir brauchen gleichzeitig
herr scholz ein glaubwürdiges großes
zuverlässiges investitionsprogramm und
von wegen rekordniveau deutschland steht
im internationalen vergleich mit der
investitionsquote am
bruttoinlandsprodukt bei ungefähr 2,5
prozent die usa bei 3,5 prozent das sind
die zahlen vorarbeiten
wenn wir uns ein beispiel an beiden und
den usa nehmen wollen mit blick auf
klimapolitik wendig sind sie wieder
dabei
mit blick auf eine investitionsprogramm
dann brauchen wir ein
investitionsprogramm genau wie wir
grünen das darlegen dass ein
investitionsfonds für 500 millionen in
den nächsten zehn jahren und kollegen
schulze ende ihrer rede und das machen
wir allerletzte wort mit meiner
investitions regelt in die
schuldenbremse ergänzt und ich hoffe
dass wir sie davon auch überzeugen
können schön dann ihre maske frau
kollegin anja rudolf die
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
bis 90 die grünen und der weg vom
rednerpult zum platz da muss die maske
angelegt werden tatsächlich zur rede
darf sie dann ihr abgenommen werden wir
wählen
und jetzt hören wir eine aussprache zu
der lesung nachtragshaushalt svenja
stadler für die sozialdemokraten ist
mitglied im haushaltsausschuss
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr verehrte
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer mehr als
ein jahr corona hat uns alle doch
verdammt viel abverlangt und viele sind
auch an die belastungsgrenze gestoßen
eine studie sagt dass kinder und
jugendliche genauso unter dieser
situation leiden die wir erwachsene und
besonders für diejenigen die viel
getragen haben
aber wenig aufgefangen wurden werden wir
insgesamt zwei milliarden euro in die
hand nehmen eine milliarde für bildung
und eine filiale für familien und da
haben wir uns doch nichts vor wir haben
doch alle gedacht dass die familie uns
auffängt dass sie funktioniert und
gleichzeitig haben wir doch gemerkt in
dieser corona pandemie dass wir gerade
den lehrern die die uns am nächsten sind
gar nicht so nah kommen durften
und auf der anderen seite gab es
wiederum menschen die durch diese
erzwungene und familiäre enge kaum diese
enge ertragen konnten und aus diesem
grund wollen wir die frühkindliche
bildung fördern
wir wollen kinder und jugendliche
unterstützen bei freizeit ferien und
sportaktivitäten und wir wollen sie
unterstützen und begleiten diese kinder
und jugendlichen im alltag
damit wollen wir auch deutlich machen
dass es eben der familie den freunden
und dem sozialen umfeld so etwas gibt
wie eine solidargemeinschaft wo es nicht
darum geht
den größten nutzen zu ziehen
in der größten not sondern ist darum
geht zu schauen wie geht es denn den
anderen den kleinen den jungen den
familien eine milliarde euro für kinder
und jugendliche die durch die schließung
von kitas und schulen halt verloren
haben
sie sollen davor geschützt werden
isoliert den sommer verbringen zu müssen
[Applaus]
wir in deutschland müssen wir dazu
befähigen und sie so unterstützen sich
zu artikulieren denn sonst sind sie doch
diejenigen die sozial isoliert werden
eine milliarde für all diejenigen die
durch corona eine soziale notlage
geraten sind besonders für kinder und
jugendlichen die eben am selbst also
selbst am wenigstens dafür können und
eben auch eine milliarde für familien
die diese belastungsgrenzen doch schon
längst überschritten haben
eine milliarde euro für kinder
jugendliche und familien damit sie sich
bewegen damit sie sport treiben können
damit sie lust haben wieder
zusammenzukommen
denn und das ist doch das entscheidende
bei all den und das wissen wir doch in
ihrem hause einige auch nicht dass
kinder den persönlichen kontakt brauchen
und der muss erhalten bleiben
kinder brauchen kinder um sich zu
entwickeln und zu leben um zu toben und
zu lachen
und wissen sie diese tatsächliche
umsetzung dieser einen milliarde liegt
vertrauensvoll in vielen händen
diese hände können über ganz deutschland
ausgebreitet ein netz darstellen um die
schwächsten unter uns aufzufangen und
ihnen zu zeigen dass sie teil dieser
gemeinschaft sind
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und sie es uns doch gemeinsam anpacken
lassen sie uns doch gemeinsam kinder
jugendliche und familien in dieser
situation unterstützen
und das können sie alle in dem sie dem
nachtragshaushalt einfach zustimmen
vielen dank das werk nicht schafft dafür
die spd fraktion als mitglied im
haushaltsausschuss und ebenso mitglied
im haushaltsausschuss der nächste redner
hier markus bohl wird es sein hier sehen
wir ihn schon für die fraktion netze
regel für die fdp fraktion marcus kühn
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren mit zahlreichen lockt downs und
immer neuen begriffen für diese ist die
bundesregierung unter immenser
schuldenmacherei durch die letzten
monate geschlägert mit der geldnot nun
der nächste nachtragshaushalt in diesem
sind mittel für wirtschaftshilfe
vorgesehen die auch bitter nötig sind
weil ganze branchen zur schließung
gezwungen worden bei denen betroffenen
kommen diese entschädigungen viel zu
langsam an
schuld daran ist eine bundesregierung
die bürokratie bürokratie ganz groß
schreibt und sie gelähmt wird vom mut
und ideenlosigkeit in diesem
bundeshaushalt werden 44 prozent über
kredite finanziert in den jahren 2020
und 20 21 beträgt die schulden am
mächtigen 370 milliarden euro also mehr
als ein normaler jahreshaushalt der
bundesrepublik eine antwort wie diese
schulden zurückbezahlt werden wie wird
diese regierung dagegen nicht die
regierung plant mit neuen schulden
soziale ruhe bis zur bundestagswahl
die bittere wahrheit wer soll das
bezahlen wird ganz klein gespielt und
damit es weniger kritik bundestag gibt
halbieren die regierungsfraktionen
einfach die debatten zeit und werden
sich draußen gerade entscheidet was mit
ihrer politik des versagens von unseren
innenstädten von hunderttausenden
arbeitsplätzen und von unserem sozialen
gefüge übrig byd wollen sie hier den
abzuzahlen schuldenberg in ein paar
minuten abhandeln
und wenn in diesem land schulden gemacht
werden muss alles auf den prüfstand auch
eine asyl rücklage
das haben wir bereits beim
nachtragshaushalt 20 20 scharf
kritisiert die schwarze null als ziel
solide haushaltspolitik das war einmal
innerhalb eines jahres hat diese
regierung mehr schulden gemacht als in
den letzten 20 jahren zusammen wer da
noch von gut durchgekommen spricht hat
die lebenswirklichkeit nicht verstanden
herzlichen dankeschön
[Applaus]
ich danke ihnen und ich gibt es dort den
letzten redner in dieser debatte doktor
reinhard brandl für die cdu csu fraktion
beraten
präsidentin verehrte kolleginnen und
kollegen diese nachtragshaushalt hat
zwei seiten
die vorderseite ist die seite des mutes
und der entschlossenheit die
entschlossenheit dass wir die schwerste
krise seit dem zweiten weltkrieg in
diesem land erfolgreich bewältigen
mit diesem nachtragshaushalt stellen der
das notwendige geld zur verfügung um
impfstoffe zu beschaffen um schnelltests
zu finanzieren um die krankenhäuser zu
unterstützen und wir finanzieren damit
praktisch den weg aus der krise heraus
mit diesem nachtragshaushalt
unterstützen wir auch die unternehmen
bestellen das geld für die
überbrückungshilfe 3 zur verfügung das
geld wird gut angenommen
die hilfen die hilfen laufen es ist gut
angelegt weil wir retten wir helfen
damit unternehmen und arbeitsplätze über
diese krise zu kommen die wir nach
dieser krise dringend brauchen um einen
neuen aufschwung für deutschland
herzustellen um meine damen und herren
wir unterstützen mit diesem
nachtragshaushalt gezielt auch die
familien
es gibt einen kinderbonus von 150 euro
pro kind der damit finanziert wird
wir alle wissen doch als unserem eigenen
erleben was es für familien bedeutet
wenn ein kind plötzlich in quarantäne
geschickt wird wenn kurzfristig
betreuungsmöglichkeiten organisiert
werden müssen mein homeschooling ansteht
wir helfen damit den familien die das
geld dringend brauchen und belegen uns
eine vorsorge
wir gehen dieses jahr in den
bundestagswahlkampf
ich werbe dafür dass cdu/csu stark
herauskommen
sie werden zu ihre parteien aber auf
jeden fall will ich dass deutschland
auch in einem wahljahr zu jederzeit
handlungsfähig ist und wir wissen nicht
was die pandemie uns noch bringen wird
was für zusätzliche impfungen noch
erforderlich sind mit dem geld stellen
wir eine pandemie vorsorge bereit um in
jeder situation auch das notwendige tun
zu können und deswegen ist es richtig
dass wir heute diesen haushalt zustimmen
aber meine damen und herren der
nachtragshaushalt hat auch eine zweite
seite die seite der sorgen oder anders
ausgedrückt die seite der schulden
wir erhöhen damit die
nettokreditaufnahme und weitere 60
milliarden euro auf 240 milliarden euro
als wären wir in den letzten sechs
jahren einen letzten sechs jahren zeuge
keinen einzigen euro neue schulden
gemacht haben sind wir jetzt im jahr
2021 soweit innerhalb von ganz kurzer
zeit dass wir 40 prozent unserer
ausgaben und schulden finanzieren müssen
und mit jedem tag mit jeder mit jedem
monat im lokal in der pandemie kommen
wir tiefer in diesen schulden strudel
hinein und es wird immer schwieriger
herauszukommen
deswegen brauchen wir die gleiche
entschlossenheit mit der wir jetzt die
pandemie bekämpfen
in den nächsten jahren um unseren
haushalt wieder in ordnung zu bringen
und meine damen und herren
es wird schwieriger es wird härter aber
es ist notwendig und wer jetzt in dieser
situation fordert die schuldenbremse
abzuschaffen der kapituliert das signal
wäre fatal
auch in richtung europa die letzte krise
war eine staatsschuldenkrise
wir müssen verhindern dass die nächste
krise wieder in die staatsschuldenkrise
wird wir müssen in deutschland in europa
so schnell wie möglich zurückkommen zu
stabilen finanzen zu konsolidieren
haushalten um auch langfristig unsere
zukunftsfähigkeit zu erhalten und
deswegen sage ich von der cdu/csu wir
unternehmen alles um die pandemie zu
bekämpfen
bestellen das notwendige geld für
impfstoffe für krankenhäuser für test
strategien bereit
aber wir wissen auch dass die rechnung
dafür noch kommt und wir sind auch
bereit in einer nächsten regierung die
notwendigen maßnahmen zu ergreifen und
im wahrsten sinne des wortes die
rechnung auch zu bezahlen
wir stehen für eine solide finanzpolitik
herzlichen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
dankeschön
das schließe ich die aussprache
[Applaus]